une femme qui écrit et une hauteur ou
une autre is entrées sont de plus en
plus nombreuses à préférer la deuxième
option
comme pascal saintonge qui écrit du
théâtre et de l'opéra ou queen ka écrit
de la poésie et qui se présente
désormais comme des autrices il ya
souvent des gens qui disent que c'est de
féminiser le langage que le ramener des
termes comme motrices mais moi je dis
plus haut que c'est de rétablir un
équilibre une langue qui politiquement
aux étés masculiniser la féminisation
sonore très important je suis une autre
is on l'entend actrice et il ya comme un
sentiment de se réapproprier les mots au
lieu de disparaître de s'unifier dans un
espèce de deux masculins normatif est
censé être pour tout le monde alors
qu'on sait très bien que ce n'est pas le
cas vous l'avez d'ailleurs sûrement
remarqué on l'entend de plus en plus le
mot autriche et la même motrices avec
trion d'autres auteurs ou tracy toi je
dis je me fais jusqu'à ne plus quand
comme ici à radio canada où le terme
n'ont en fait jamais été proscrits moi
j'en parle depuis au moins 28 ans de ce
moment là j'ai toujours mentionné le
fait qu'on existait mais tu sais
et généralement ça génère un petit pour
y passer des gens trouvent ça bizarre ce
moulin il aimait pas montré sous un
petit peu et congrue alors qu'il est
parfaitement bien fort mais ça viendra
au texte latin
donc c'est bien traduit c'est le mot
qu'on devrait optimiser en principe mais
vain le départ se monte à nous prêter
populaire et encore aujourd'hui c'est la
forme auteur qui est la plus répandue
prenez seulement votre cellulaire
écrivait l'auteur aucun problème mais
essayer d'écrire l'autre russe votre
caractère va plutôt vous proposez
l'autriche le petit robert lui va vous
dire que le mot crise est rare et qu'on
trouve la forme auteur e sur le modèle
du français canadien
on en a aussi parlé à des éditeurs et la
plupart nous disent qu'ils reconnaissent
le titre d'autres et celles qui le
demande mais que c'est le terme auteurs
qui est encore privilégiée
on est en train de cheminer puisse dire
bon peut-être qu'on pourrait
éventuellement se tourner vers autre ici
mais il ya quand même certaines
certaines collaboratrice qui préfèrent
encore nettement auteurs eux parce
qu'elles sont plus habitués parce que ça
fait partie de notre terminologie au
québec est ce que plusieurs femmes qui
défendent le terme autres ils disent ce
qu'elles veulent pas nécessairement
l'imposer à tout
elle demande surtout qu'on leur laisse
le choix je pense pas que je veux que ce
soit systématique
par contre je pense que mon seul petit
souhait c'est que les gens arrêtent de
tickets de faire des phases drôle quand
je viens me présenter comme aux tristes
commence à faire le même procès ce que
j'ai fait avec autrice jeu en train de
le faire avec metteuse en scène donc le
plus on utilise les mots plus il existe
dans notre société et plus on se rend
compte de leur importance au lieu des
marginaux